so question for the guys how many bodies
is Too Many Bodies let's put the number
to it depends on the age okay let's say
so the average age the average age of
first marriage in the UK is 31. okay
what would you how many bodies has too
many bodies for a 31 year old jeez hey
I'm glad you first
um over double figures over double so 10
10 10 and up okay
now we've got really it's 20 22. you're
being nice you you wouldn't want to hear
20 until I agree with 20 I think twenty
you would marry a woman with 20 bodies
would I marry a woman with 20 bodies
no
okay okay okay okay that was too much
what's the minimum okay would you let me
just ask the question a different way
would you marry a girl with 10 bodies
yes or no yes would you marry 10 yeah
yeah
well yeah what about you okay would you
marry a girl with 15 bodies yes or no
potentially potentially yeah yeah
I think 15 is the max for me okay 20. no
no just getting sticky um yeah a hard
okay yes yes okay so 20 no no it's 15 is
a Max 15 is the max
okay now what percent of women that are
31 do you think have less than 15 bodies
about five percent
about twenty percent twenty percent I
know I'm gonna ask the women this too go
ahead 25 25 what do you think what
percent of women that are 31 have less
than 15 bodies have less than yeah
uh just about yeah also say your name
your age and where you're from
50. I'm Christina from Hackney and 35.
okay welcome to the show
um how many percent of I don't know
wait come back to me it's okay what
percent of women do you think have less
than 15 bodies at 31.
yeah
ten percent ten percent I'll say 50 50.
I don't even I'm just totally shocked
when you think 16 is a legal age you're
always thinking about 40 14 and you're
thinking 15 that's like
that's that's more than one a year
mm-hmm
wow so what are you
I'm just that well you're shy like
that's a lot or a little that's a lot
yeah in like 14 years 15. yeah wow and
that's like going that's what's going on
now I yeah yeah that's mostly one that's
not relationship that's just like
shagging isn't it well that's that's
because modern women are side chicks
because because again it's a it's a no
no because remember it's a smaller and
smaller percentage of of men that are
sleeping with all the girls so if you
look at dating app data like women only
swipe right like five percent of the
time up to you know 10 15 that's high so
women are and the number one peop way
that people meet is online dating
and so women are side chicks because
they're all sleeping with the same guys
because if you want a guy that's over
six foot that's fifteen percent of men
you waving well I am he's single do you
want to be if you want to be one of the
girls
and so um yeah so like modern women are
side chicks because that's disgusting
it's a small percentage of men that are
sleeping with all the girls one out of
three men under 30 or their virgins are
haven't had sex in the past year
so like so that indicates the trend
Which is less and less and less and like
the big frustration that I hear from men
is basically that girls get ran through
by like the guys they actually want in
their 20s and then they hit like 30 and
then they're like please take me and
then they finally come around to the
like guys in their friend zone basically
at like 30. sounds about right is that
something you've seen through the oldest
one here would you say that's a valid
complaint
yeah I mean when they get older they
always try and look back at what they
could have had
but but then it's too late because
they've got loads of kids behind them
and
weird baby fathers and yeah I mean weird
habits and
I'm just talking about the 15. the 15
what what did you think okay okay at 30
how many how many what do you think most
women had from your generation
I think you just stick with the same
person for a couple of years
but
so you would have said like five by the
end of 30 but 50 yeah because the thing
is like the girls are sleeping with that
small percentage of guys right so those
guys aren't going to stick with a girl
for a couple of years because it's with
the girls but because the thing is like
guys will sleep with anything so a guy
that's an eight nine or ten I'll sleep
with a four five or six even if he's
never seen it been seen in public with
her ever having sex
and so and so it's like uh
that is disgusting it's a shock I'm
thinking 15 Partners in 14 years
yeah
you think that's a lot
in today's generation it's not a lot
it's a I will say it's a different time
yeah it's a different time yeah one a
year
I'll take back my hot girl Decay because
that was nothing because I could have
had like them 15 men in the Whole Decade
let alone oh yeah it's more like like
you know how you guys slept together for
a couple years it's like a couple of
months nowadays um
men need to be preserved in this moment
this well why would they when they have
like that small percentage of men if
they have women on a silver platter why
would they they have pride in who they
joke why
because
listen about you you wanna if you're
gonna go there and sleep we'll go make
sure you're like number three number
four you don't want to be number nine
number ten number 11 number 12 number
15.
because then you're you're 15. imagine
if you're number 15. honestly all team
members for you honestly and you heard
and you heard the panel right the
majority of i-31 have probably slept
with more
when the girl said oh we can lie about
it if you're 15 body in the first by the
age of five of course you're going to
want to lie she was like oh what if they
don't know about the body count what if
you know about it but guys no oh my God
so you think a man should feel shame if
he knows he's the 15th guy to have had
sex with
yeah you don't know it's been there
before you
do that no man can I try and put it into
retrospective and essentially if a guy
is the 15th guy yeah he's going ignoring
I'm not staying I'm leaving straight
after so whoever's number 16 whoever's
number 17 it is what it is yeah and then
it will get to someone who's like number
30 and they're like
I'll wipe it and it's like that person
is the one that lost and everyone else
got it for well I will say something on
the other end though a lot of guys do
cat because they'll come on these shows
and they'll say they wouldn't wipe a
girl over a certain count and I know who
they're dating
and I'm like
I'm just gonna mind that I'm definitely
liked girls who have had high body
counts I have but how did you know they
had did you ask them or they they happen
to be honest with me and I take their
word for it because it's not a number
that you would just openly want to say
but you know it's always in my mind as
much as I like what they say what number
[Music]
I think you just thought the right well
about if my friend they're gonna get do
you know that that's the thing is you
can't really control who you like or who
you fall but you can control how you
deal with the situation or how you
operate or how you choose to move
forward
when you found out about the body count
where you repulsed
um I wouldn't say repulse no because I
just don't really get that surprised in
this day and age like you know the
figures yeah
did you go there no why not
because it it never came about well if
you come about where you're still gone
with the three figures yeah yeah yeah
I think maybe Medicare undo their
biology they're biologically
predisposition to want to spread their
seed but they're also biologically
predispositioned to want to want to
ensure paternity so like historically if
a girl slept around they don't know if
the kid she's having is his and that
even still happens nowadays like you see
videos all the time where this dude
that's been raising a kid for 10 years
finds out this kid isn't his and girls
can do that legally there's no
ramifications where if guys don't play
child support they go to jail but a girl
can trap a guy and crazy so Mori made a
whole career off that real yeah and
so like guys can't undo how they feel
about it I don't think like that
automatically if she has a high body
count and if she is in a relationship
she actually you know loved the man she
been with she gonna sleep automatically
with someone else so easily that doesn't
honestly we should like distinguish
between when you single are you afraid
to do whatever you wish and when you are
in our relationship so it doesn't mean
you're gonna be not loyal
do you know what I mean like more it's
more likely your habits are who you are
why you need to label someone just
because yeah it's not based on your
actions so so same for men I would say
man can actually is actually allowed to
have high body count so what I what I
supposed to think if I'm actually going
to marry the man they gonna cheat on me
but women don't women women don't care
because I'm I'm a woman no no so women
women don't care you don't see girls
lining up to date Drake and saying oh no
his body counts too high how will I go
like no no but but but the opposite of
that Brittany graner Griner whatever her
name is like guys are like oh Jesus
Christ oh no no no no no yeah because
Brittany and she's beautiful but
Brittany Reynolds
and your how your habits like make up
who you are so if you've been doing
something for a decade how like just
like if a guy cheated on every single
girl before you he's probably gonna
cheat on you too duh personally for me
if if a guy's body count is like the
three figures I'd be just as disgusted
don't matter if he's Drake Chris but I
don't care I'd be repulsed to be honest
if it's 50 depending on how old he is
again I'd still feel a bit icky is it oh
yeah no you're gonna be icky as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
but please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible